avec l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir que
claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous comme d'habitude on va essayer
d'approfondir un sujet et de le
décrypter alors pourquoi n'y at il rien
sur l'immigration dans les cordes de
retrait conclu entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni on voit à quel point
c'est un sujet majeur parce que toute la
campagne du brics ita a été fondé sur
l'idée que le royaume uni voulait
récupérer le contrôle national de ses
frontières et que et le voulait rejeté
aussi l'immigration alors cela dit vous
avez bien fait la distinction entre
l'immigration légale et l'immigration
illégale
il y avait en grande bretagne près de 5
millions de travailleurs tout à fait
légaux ayant un travail à un métier
parmi eux un million trois cent mille
son parti inquiet sur la situation post
break 6 sur leur situation personnelle
il en reste un peu plus de 3 millions
qui devaient se faire enregistrer avant
le 1er juillet donc la semaine dernière
pour avoir le droit à un permis de
travail en grande bretagne donc à
travers des des inscriptions assez
complexe sur le plan administratif mais
évidemment le royaume uni l'économie
britannique a besoin de deux
travailleurs qualifiés qui entrent
légalement au royaume uni et pour cela
elle est à vis des critères pour pouvoir
chez revenir au royaume uni et avoir un
permis de travail et bien il faut
d'abord avoir un contrat de travail que
ce contrat de travail peut qu'on perd
contre n 1 c'est un comprennent un
salaire suffisamment élevé pour pouvoir
subvenir à ses besoins démontrer qu'on
parle anglais qu'on a des qualifications
professionnelles requises
donc c'est une immigration choisie pour
le reste pour l'immigration illégale
eh bien vous avez très bien décrit ce
que dit le ministre de l'intérieur
madame à peu près 6 patel qui
effectivement a dit
je ya je crois que elle rendrait la
manche impraticable pour les petites
embarcations
et pour ce faire elle a nommé un ancien
commandant de marine pour s'occuper
d'eux précisément de ce problème et donc
on peut penser que effectivement ce sera
efficace
ça veut dire que pendant un certain
temps eh bien c'est la france qui va
devoir s'occuper de ses candidats à
l'exil au royaume uni parce que ils ont
de bonnes raisons de vouloir aller au
royaume-uni soyons déjà de la famille
soit elles viennent d'un pays
anglophones africains par exemple soit
il considère que finalement ils pourront
s'intégrer relativement facilement dans
cette société
alors maintenant c'est fini on ferme la
frontière et donc pendant un certain
temps il va probablement y avoir un
afflux de ce genre de réfugiés du côté
de calais on avait renforcé
considérablement des forces policières
pour traiter ce problème mais il est
vraisemblable que vu les signaux qui
sont envoyées depuis londres la
discussion va s'exercer et que très
rapidement il y aura moins de candidats
à aller en grande bretagne et ils ne
font que traverser la france et viennent
de beaucoup plus loin
ils sont entrés dans l'union européenne
en effet dans un autre pays mais qui
n'est pas à la france la france n'est
qu'un un lieu de transit est un lieu de
passage et ceci pose donc un problème à
gérer et qui est un problème qui est une
conséquence du bric site claude blanc
présent y at il une autre au sujet de
préoccupation dans le sillage du bric
site ghana beaucoup évidemment il ya la
pêche est juste avant pâques on a vu que
les pêcheurs méditerranéens des pêcheurs
parlons de normandie en france ne se
voyait plus reconnaître leurs droits
traditionnels dans les eaux de jersey
que le traité de granville n'était pas
reconnue par les accords du bric site et
finalement plus généralement sur les
problèmes de pêche
nos pêcheurs se plaignent que les
licences qui devrait leur être accordées
ne le sont pas dans les conditions
conformes aux traités qu'on réduit leurs
droits de pêche peut quelquefois on leur
contestent leurs bras de pêche dans les
eaux britanniques alors que pendant une
période de transition assez longue et
doivent être
ils ont été reconnus par le traité et
puis deuxième sujet peut-être
politiquement encore plus important
c'est le sujet de l'annex irlande au
traité de break site que monsieur boris
johnson n'a pas l'intention de respecter
alors il ya eu des incidents là aussi
juste avant pas que pour l'anniversaire
de l'accord du vendredi saint qui
prévoyait l'accord entre les dirigeants
du nord et les autres participants de
façon à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
frontières entre l'irlande du nord parti
du royaume uni et la république
d'irlande est l'objet précisément de
cette annexe à l'accord du bric site
qu'on appelle l' annexe irlande c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de rétablissement de
frontières physiques ni pour les
personnes ni pour les marchandises et
pour cela on a inventé un dispositif
assez ingénieux qui consiste à ce que
les foules et les contrôles sanitaires
douaniers produits d'origine et lieu
dans les ports britanniques
éventuellement dans les ports d'irlande
du nord et pas à la limite entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande
mais laury johnson évidemment a fort à
faire avec les ses partisans les plus
nationalistes qui ne veulent pas de ces
contrôles à l'intérieur du royaume uni
et pour le moment on a reporté
l'échéance on vit dans une période de
transition qui ne doit pas durer
longtemps parce que ça veut dire qu'il
ya une brèche dans le marché unique
européen et que des produits des animaux
des moutons néo zélandais pourrait
pénétrer sur le territoire du marché
unique en passant par l'irlande du nord
on l'a appris d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une
plutôt bonne nouvelle pour londres après
ce break site long qui est à nouveau le
premier centre financier en europe pour
les échanges d'actions ça vous étonne
pardonnez moi mais pas du tout parce que
ce petit jeu entre amsterdam et londres
en fait amsterdam était devenue la
première place financière pour les
échanges d'actions en bourse au début de
l'année après le break site parce que 6
milliards d'activité s'était déplacé de
londres vers le continent principalement
en effet vers amsterdam et ce qui s'est
passé ces jours ci c'est que le royaume
est une grande bretagne a conclu un
accord avec la suisse
alors que la suisse a toujours un
contentieux avec l'union européenne la
grande-bretagne qui n'est plus dans
l'union européenne a pu conclure cet
accord avec la suisse et par conséquent
la suisse a rétabli les échanges
d'actions suisse sud à la bourse de
londres
et cet afflux d'affaires a fait passer
très légèrement d'ailleurs le volume
d'affaires de londres devant celui
d'amsterdam
mais d'ici quelques mois il est probable
que le contentieux qui est un
contentieux global entre l'union
européenne et la suisse saura trouver
les solutions et que l'activité des
échanges et des actions suisse reprendra
dans toutes les bourses européennes et
se répartira à travers les diverses
bourse suivant la l'attrait qu'elle
exerce sur les différents opérateurs
alors justement cet attrait fait l'objet
d'un débat politique parce que le
ministre des finances britannique a dit
très récemment qu'il allait prendre des
mesures pour rendre la bourse de londres
beaucoup plus attractive que les autres
bourses en facilitant notamment
l'inscription à la bourse de londres
d'entreprises qui sont dans les
nouvelles technologies et la directrice
générale de la bourse de londres a
enchéri mais avec une clause de prudence
en disant qu'on ait fait tout serait
fait pour faciliter l'accès des
entreprises à la bourse de londres par
conséquent pour récupérer des capitaux
pour financer leurs activités mais que
la bourse de londres voulait respecter
les normes des normes strictes des
normes qui sont
qui ont su retrouver coeur sur le plan
international et notamment à l'intérieur
de l'europe
autrement dit la menace qui planait dont
on a souvent parlé d'un singapour sur la
thalie et à dire de mesures extrêmement
laxiste vis-à-vis des entreprises
vis-à-vis des opérateurs financiers
eh bien ce n'est pas pour demain car ce
n'est pas l'intérêt des acteurs
britanniques ce n'est pas l'intérêt de
la cité de passer pour un lieu permissif
où on peut faire un peu tout et
n'importe quoi comme cela est le cas sur
certaines places financières asiatiques
merci claude blanchemaison d'avoir été
avec nous en direct